[Music]
welcome to there be spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to x-men Dark Phoenix wraps up the
Fox franchise and slightly meandering
fashion that sees the series go out with
more of a whimper than a bang there is
however still a lot to unpack from the
movie and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film its final few
scenes and what the studio originally
had planned for the ending of the film
this is full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't seen Dark Phoenix yet and don't
want anything room for yourself then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of Dark Phoenix the movie
opens with Jean Grey accidentally
killing her mother in a car crash due to
her inability to truly control her
powers this is a motif that follows the
character throughout the film and this
movie is really about her mastering her
abilities as a mutant before they
inevitably consume her and the world
from here we watch as she grows into her
role as one of the most powerful x-men
I'm sorry should I say ex women I'm
alright guys I mean all the women round
here they do all the save in your dead
never mind anyway
Xavier adopts Jean after Berlin her
father was unable to deal with what she
did the plot twist is what really pushes
Jean over the edge in the film and it's
a rubella it's certainly a big one this
happens at the film's midpoint and it's
sort of a bit of a gut punch for the
character that really sends her off the
deep end now the majority of this movie
takes place in the 90s and we discover
that unlike the original timeline the
x-men are celebrated and no longer seen
as a public threat that doesn't mean
everything is fine though and some of
the characters still bear resentment
towards Xavier who their view is
controlling them after a space mission
goes haywire the x-men are called to
rescue the astronauts on board and it's
during this scene at Gina's Left Behind
and absorbs the solar flare which if we
discover is the Phoenix force from here
we are introduced to Smith played by
Jessica Chester
who is a member of an alien race known
as the d'bari
fans of the comic will recognize his
race as victims of the Phoenix during
the Dark Phoenix saga and will remember
that their planet was destroyed by the
titular Beast urine run similar to that
the movie centers around the d'bari
attempting to find a new home and we
learn that they are a shape-shifting
alien race which highly plays into why
the movie had its original ending we
shot in my opinion anyway I'll get into
that later we'll just focus on the main
plot for now the d'bari wish to unleash
the phoenix upon the earth and claim the
planet for themselves having absorbed
the solar flare Jean is unable to
control it and unwittingly unleashes a
blast that leads her on a path of
discovery towards her true origin this
is where the film really ramps up and
it's also in this conflict that mystique
is murdered by Jean she was the best
x-men I mean woman I mean next person
whatever gender she's mimicking at the
time just just please don't call them
x-men we all know how offensive that
term is these days anyway beast who is
planning to run away with her is
heartbroken and Jean now on the run
please to magneto there's some awesome
action scenes here and whilst the pacing
is really off it still doesn't stop
these brief moments from being enjoyable
beast joins Magneto after they unite
over their love of their fallen ex
person and they agree to take jean out
now this is where the film really tries
to get you invested in its final act
unfortunately a lot of the elements are
so poorly handle at this point and it
becomes difficult to fully enjoy the
action no matter how cool it looks I
really wonder what this final act could
have been like if we've gotten what was
originally shot and though the powers
used here are pretty great I feel like
if it hadn't remained in space like
originally planned that the movie would
have been elevated a lot or Smith
attempting to steal the Phoenix force
from gene who is at this point
unconscious ambushes the x-men with her
allies and whilst the mutants put up a
fight they aren't really a match for the
extraterrestrials get it extra
extraterrestrial never mind
Charles has no other option but to wake
Jean up and she wipes out all of the
aliens pretty easily Smith still
determined to get the Phoenix force out
won't give up and states that as Jean
can't control the Phoenix if she kills
her then she will
our friends thus Jean flies them into
space blowing the two of them up and
apparently killing them both in the
process
Scott renames the school after Jean
Quicksilver who was put in a coma
because the writers didn't know how else
to use him when he's pretty much
impossible to beat wakes up and Charles
leaves for Europe in a scene similar to
Inception though this feels more like a
nightmare the character is tracked down
by magneto who in true franchise fashion
wishes to meet up with him for a game of
chess now whilst Jean is apparently dead
similar to the ending of x2 we do get a
faint Phoenix impression in the sky and
thus it's safe to assume that she
survived the explosion however what I
don't get is why they left the final
film of the franchise on a cliffhanger
when they knew that there wouldn't be
really anything after it perhaps this is
no cliffhanger and it's just a way for
the x-men franchise to close out with a
happy ending but I feel like we as an
audience could have had more closure
after being fans for the best part of
two decades this ending is either gonna
really annoy you or it's gonna make you
smile because you know jeans still out
there but for me it was just a bit of a
disappointment now from the off it's
pretty clear that the film shares
several similarities with the recently
released MCU movie Captain Marvel James
McAvoy recently said in an interview
that the latter part the film was reshot
as it was too similar to another
property and it's crystal clear that
this is the case Chastain's character
was clearly originally meant to be a
scroll and the refugees in search of a
planet to appear as a theme in this film
perhaps in the ending the Phoenix
rehoused the alien race instead of
killing them and this is why the movie
was supposed to have its final act in
space we may never know for definite but
that seems like the most likely
conclusion for me it's sort of a shame
that this film was originally supposed
to be released in the latter part of
2018 as this would have meant that it
seemed more original when compared to
Captain Marvel now overall whilst I do
love the x-men franchise yes even the
Dead films in it
I feel like Dark Phoenix is a pretty big
disappointment the lack of a true story
is evident here and it's crazy that Fox
have once again dropped the ball with
such a beloved storyline I have no idea
why they got the guy that wrote The Last
Stand to write and direct this but a
guess in Hollywood you fail of
it's the Stars characters and fans
deserve more from this and it's
definitely a movie that leaves a bitter
taste in the mouth ultimately this is
hard to recommend and it's probably the
most disappointing movie of the air for
me personally and that's why it gets
five out of ten
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if you disagree with me
and my overall reaction make sure you
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my ranking
of all the films from worst to best in
the franchise which will be linked at
the end this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]